I have to do so many Impressions
okay what you told me it's not just
telling you don't worry no that no one
can hear us let me tell you what is like
being your friend is okay you can't you
can't help doing the impersonation
because it becomes a language yeah you
and I speak a language together many of
your other friends do this too yeah I
know because you do constant
impersonations it's you can only really
talk to you in impersonation it's my
fault I'm asking you not to talk to me
that I'm not saying it's a fault I will
try to abide by that but I would also I
will try to abide by I would also be
aware of the fact that you have
basically created a language of
interaction with all of your friends
myself
that does involve these impersonations
yeah yeah yeah yeah